and welcome to
it's not just code managing an open
source project I'd like to introduce the
open source program director from posit
Tracy TM
[Applause]
uh thank you I'm super excited to be
here today speaking on this topic you
may wonder why this topic is in this
session and that's because I had a
surprise opportunity to get this talk
today because someone
um but this is one of my favorite topics
and I love the panel discussion
yesterday so I'm excited to get to spend
a little bit more time on this topic
and so
I'm preaching to the choir in this
conference to say that open source
software is the roads and bridges of
Technology
so when I say that you know what what do
we mean
you know open up your phone your social
media your news your medical records
your bank they are all using free and
public code and this is a theme that
we've been hearing throughout this
meeting especially uh in the panel
yesterday and this is something that
Nadia ekball highlighted in a report
that she did when she was a VC she was
looking for the biggest sort of unfunded
opportunities in the tech space and what
she encountered was open source
um and so she worked on this report
to generate ideas about
why this was happening and what the
structure of Open Source looked like
but what we see in open source is this
sort of
inverse pyramid structure right where we
have a lot of people who are using it
users who use an open source solution as
is without adapting or modifying it this
is the biggest group of folks out there
using open source software
there's integrators people who integrate
one or more open source components to
create an application
um so they're maybe doing a little bit
modification a little more what's going
on under the hood in some of these
projects
um then you have contributors people who
provide changes and improvements to the
open source
office system
and then finally you have maintainers
and these are the people who develop and
control the main source code and manage
the project
so we see that this is not necessarily
like a very stable structure
um the way that it's designed and I
think that a lot of us in this room have
experienced this this feeling of sort of
being somewhere in this pyramid where
there is a weight on top of you in terms
of the responsibilities that you have to
your team and your communities
um and so a lot of times too these are
volunteers right so these are not
necessarily even positions that are paid
the people that are supporting these
structures
so why is this a topic that is so
interesting exciting and important to me
well I started in open source software
development in bioinformatics
for Math and I wrote some software that
mainly I used
um but you know my team used it too and
I started to write projects that that
got more use and I started to encounter
like some of the edge cases of some of
these things
um but I also realized that especially
in bioinformatics one thing that was
really limiting the advancement of being
able to use genomic data was people with
the ability to use data science to
answer the questions that were important
to them
um so I was a part of founding an
organization called the carpentries
which is a non-profit organization
teaching researchers how to do data
science and so in software development
and for me that really marked this
transition actually in this pyramid
where I thought about like oh I'm
developing a Pittsburgh software I'm a
part of this pyramid but when I
transitioned to running an organization
I really realized what that meant around
maintaining free resources and
everything that went into it and that I
had zero training in end of it
alas my software development skills were
not particularly useful in conflict
resolution
in gaining money running effective
meetings so these are all things I say I
tried to get my MBA via Google every
time I was like I don't know how to do
that but I bet somebody knows how to
decided so I would Google it
um so that was like kind of this
beginning of this journey for me and
then I was on the board of numb Focus
super excited to be back here at this
event
um and I saw that this wasn't just like
a knee problem
I wasn't the only one struggling with
this all of the projects kind of under
that known Focus umbrella we're really
struggling with a lot of those same
challenges
um so now I am at posit uh I am the open
source program director
um and so I have the opportunity to work
with open source developers every day
and I'll talk about like how kind of
closet fits into this ecosystem of Open
Source and I'm the chair of the board
for pi open inside
so as I said this journey where I didn't
know what I was doing uh is not my
journey alone uh there are certainly
people who do know what they're doing as
they get into this
um but in General open source developers
have been trained to build roads
and then we're suddenly asking them to
maintain and manage the road crews for
our city so where do they get those
skills is this even something that
people are interested in
um how do we start to think about this
so why do we want to talk about it at a
meeting like this
and that's because shared challenges are
also shared opportunities
[Music]
we are all here together we have a lot
of shared challenges but this also means
we don't need to be alone these are
shared opportunities for us to navigate
these Waters together and talk about
what some of the solutions are
so one thing in particular we can
provide support training and resources
for open safe Source maintainers
together
we don't each need to be doing this on
our own
so what does this look like
so I'm going to talk about five
different areas that we can think about
in maintaining open source projects and
none of this here is a should
these are all questions these are things
that you can consider
every project is going to be different
if I'm going to say should for me is not
should for you so in general what I'm
posing are more questions than answers
in this
but one of the challenges when you're
working in an open source project is
that you get going on the project and
that's sort of where all your energy is
and so you don't have that space to step
back and like think
why am I doing this what's important
um so it just has sense in this room how
many people have contributed to an open
source project
and how many people feel like they're in
some kind of like management or
maintenance group and how many of you
have had training in business or
conflict resolution
yeah okay great perfect if you all had
well then you were gonna tell me more
please
um right so these are things that I only
realize like far into a project that I
needed to consider and then again like
especially working across all these
different open source projects
realistically Figures were things that
we wanted to be thinking about from
this so the very first thing this maybe
seems a little bit strange
but is identifying your project goals
because a lot of times when you start a
project
um you are trying to solve a problem
that you have
and maybe you write it just for yourself
or for your team and then some people
pick it up and they start using it and
you're like wow that's cool that's
amazing and sort of before you know it
other people have sort of like decided
what this project is about without you
and that's that's not bad but you
actually do get to decide with the goals
of this project are just because you
start something doesn't mean that you
need to maintain it forever doesn't mean
that you need to implement every feature
so it's worth taking the time to
consider your goals so the first thing
you have to do is take a breath because
again this project may have gotten away
from you a little bit
so who is this for
who are you creating this project for
what's the kind of person that you're
thinking about this tool is for
how reliable is this going to be is this
something that people are going to be
using in production in big environments
or is this something that someone's
using in a lab and you can kind of print
out a bunch of error messages or share
it with some caveats what's the
importance of reliability for this
software
what kinds of input would be important
and
I'm not like data input but what kind of
feedback what do you want to hear about
what do you need to learn as people use
this
and then finally and this is actually
really hard but what's your vision of
what will be possible if the software
exists
the world and the future will be like X
if the software exists and that seems
like oh maybe that's a grand statement
but like you're doing it for those
reasons what is your vision for this
song
so these are really hard questions like
everything I'm posing here none of it is
a just it is all something that you have
to spend time with and it takes time but
it's something that is worth taking a
day or go take a walk in a park and take
your notebook it's hard to answer these
questions for yourself or with your team
when you're in front of your computer
all right
the next one is managing expectations
actually get to set your own boundaries
the challenge in this is you have to
create those boundaries those
expectations and you have to communicate
them
so
because it's about managing the
expectations of the people who are using
and contributing to
um so again we have five things to
configure there are certainly more
um
stage of the project
like where is it in its development
how do you want people to treat each
other in the space of your project and
how do they you want
how do you want to handle PR submissions
and reviews
uh templates this is something that I'm
excited about
a ways that exist already to help you
manage your expectations and then
licensing something that came up in the
panel yesterday
so stage of the project I really love uh
this concept in this diagram
life cycle package a deposit is one of
the developer in the airport
and so there are other things that you
can consider but this is actually really
important this idea of is this an
experimental package are you going to be
contributing to it a lot like are things
going to be changing really quickly is
it stable is it someone thing that
people can use and they expect there not
to be many changes so you could rely on
it to behave in a certain way and then
importantly
superseded and deprecated
again if you create something it doesn't
need to last forever one example is I
wrote some software in graduate school
that worked with 454 genomic data that
package does not need to exist anymore
because people even generate 4548
anymore from genomic sequencers that's a
pretty easy one but there's other
reasons why a package might not really
need to be actively maintained anymore
so that's for you to think about I think
like you know that stage between
experimental and stable is unclear like
nothing is a fine line and you kind of
might find yourself in a different mode
without realizing it but this is
something to keep in mind and come back
to
how people treat each other
I think this is something that's like
been really positive in the python
community over the last several years is
the expectations of how people behave in
code repositories and at conference and
a lot of tech has been around
really again setting those expectations
not just saying like hey we should be
nice but let's write it down we'll just
what do we mean when we say that what
are the consequences for that um
how is it that you share that something
isn't going well and being explicit
about that being important this is a
place where templates are great GitHub
actually has a code of conduct template
so when you start a GitHub repository
you can select this and add a code of
conduct to your repository I will say
just putting a code of conduct in your
repository is not enough you have to be
how you might handle something that
comes up but this is a really important
way of writing down what you mean when
you say how you
to treat each other
this is important for you right like how
do you want people to treat you
PR submission and review contributing
guidelines right you see contributing
guidelines a lot in GitHub repositories
um so I like the timing of this is so
awesome because I'm so excited about
this okay so um PR submission and review
So within posit we have an open source
uh reading group uh and we're reading a
series of blog posts about like good
pull requests doing good reviews of pull
requests and from this uh Davis Bond put
together this tidy verse tidy Team Code
review principle
um and so you can see there's a lot of
categories here about like what does a
good PR look like what is a good VR
review look like look like um so this is
something like expectations for the team
might look like
we think this is already what we do but
we're trying it out
um but it's also another great way to
externalize like you know how is it hey
what's a good pi
and one thing that I
thought of that uh that Davis and Leonel
worked on together is these like
patterns of collaboration
so close-knit collaboration understudy
external contributors so the key thing
here is again if you're thinking about
managing X itations
the first thing to do is which mode of
collaboration are we in
right not every kind of pull request or
every kind of thing that you're working
on is going to necessarily have the same
relationship but if you agree like this
is where we are then you have a set of
ideas about like how your what the
timing is going to be and will you get
back to me on that PR like will you just
edit and merge like things like that
um and again it's like oh well yeah we
kind of all knew this already but
writing it down really helps us stay
true to what we think we should be doing
and helps other people on our CNR
process and maybe something they can use
if they're building a new
okay templates this is my favorite like
whenever you're trying to do something
new it's like somebody's done it before
and there might be a template so always
Google whatever you're trying to do and
template
um so there's a lot of great stuff uh in
the space there's readme's this readme
project are on better documentation we
already talked about the code of conduct
you know read me uh straight from GitHub
now
um other kinds of they're not exactly
templates but are like what are good
package development structures so like
the type of Earth has uh used this
package that is like you use this to do
package development
um so it helps you have good practices
in terms of what your package looks like
and then also your packages look like
other people so people sort of know what
to expect Pi openside has been working
on these python open source package
development guide so if you're excited
about python packaging and like who
isn't I'm serious like this is amazing
this is Leia wasser is doing this work
and Juanita is maybe here she's going to
be joining that project for just a
little while they have put so much work
into like really having Community
conversations to say
um you know what works what doesn't work
what's practical
um incredible really incredible work
that is really important in these spaces
about again what does a python package
look like when you're starting because
like what can you expect from the
packages when you take a look at them
and Licensing actually don't have too
much to say about licensing I thought it
was an interesting conversation
yesterday
um
yeah one thing that was interesting was
that is it really open source a
conversation that was a part of that
panel and
um open source is defined by a set of
licenses so if it has an open source
license it is open source and when we
talk about governance we can talk about
maybe some distinctions there
um but yeah you have to you have to make
your choices on your Source license
all right
maximum easy one
who is involved in government's
conversations and open source project
right now
okay I was like no one what
um okay so this is this is hard for sure
um this is where having your practicals
is important when I said like what kinds
of input do you need who is this for uh
what do you what do you want to do right
like how much time do you have
um so these are some of the bdfl model
is a pretty popular One open governance
I think this is where we kind of got
into this conversation of is it really
open source like open source is a
license but there's kind of this open
governance idea there's a community or a
committee or something something like
that like python is not right but before
um who's going to make your technical
decisions versus your organizational
decisions
um and who's gonna who's gonna do these
things you might decide I'm an amazing
structure and then be like cool and now
who's going to do it and everybody looks
up there
then it's not really going to be a
structure that's going to work for your
team or you need to think about how are
you going to recruit someone who's
excited about this
so yeah that's definitely a whole topic
I'd like I'd love to have like a
conversation about governance in
particular so the last one then I think
is a financial support
so this was again something that that
came up yesterday
um and I think this this is from some of
my experience having transition from a
developer to Leading an organization
was the recognition that this is really
I mean in our case it was a non-profit
but the non-profit or business
um num Focus takes some of that away by
having this project structure will do
your back office for you but you still
we come back to these like how do you
make decisions how do you bring in money
how do you make decisions about how to
spend money I mean this is again like
just a really challenging thing if
you've been a developer you might not
have experience in thinking about how
you generate Revenue how you spend money
so like that might be a little
controversial
maybe you don't think that that's the
way it should be maybe it's not the way
it should be it is for you maybe it's
not what you've seen but I think it's
something to consider and appreciate
so then if we do need to think about
money
how much money do we need to meet the
project goals what do you again what are
you trying to do how many people do you
need what roles do you need how much
does it cost to pay those people or how
much does it cost for your
infrastructure
align how you get your money with your
project goals this is some of the best
advice that I heard
um
if your project goals are something and
you create a way to generate money that
is not aligned with the goals you're
actually running two businesses right
you're running the business that
generates the money and then you're
wanting the business that does the other
thing
um and unless you can find a way to web
them together the money one often wins
in terms of some of the time because you
have commitments that you've made that
you need to honor
um and so when we got a grant my Grant
Management Foundation Chris Spencer gave
us that advice and I think that that has
been some of the best the best I've
heard that's very easy to not recognize
at the beginning
can you receive money GitHub sponsors is
great that helps with some of this but
again this is actually non-trivial
sometimes how do actually people pay you
and then do people know what they're
paying for and how you abuse it
hear this live in open source I said it
a lot myself we're doing great work why
don't they just give us money
that's not really how things work
um unfortunately but actually not
unfortunately like people want to
understand what they're paying for and
how you'll use it and so all of these
other questions about like what's your
governance discussion structure how do
you make decisions all of these things
is really important actually for getting
money because you can say I you know we
need money for one and a half developers
and someone to write documentation uh if
we have this money this person will do
this this person will do this you'll see
at the end of the year that these
features are implemented we have a
maintenance structure and we have a set
of docs that like you and your team
needs it right again there has to be
this kind of like public good is really
important and true but
people need to understand how you're
using money and have confidence that
like you actually know how you're going
to be spending
okay so Nadia ekball as a part of this
study into roads and bridges also had
this really nice this lemonade stand a
handy guide the financial support for
open source so it's a GitHub repository
if you Google it um so she talks about a
few different models for open source
structure and I do sort of
I don't I'm not saying something's
missing but but the piece of okay this
is how you bring the money in but I
don't know how you spend it and how you
talk about how you spend it as
it is so pause it so one of the reasons
I am super excited to be at Plaza and
why I can deposit in the first place is
because I think it's one of the
um a great model for supporting open
source software
um so we have this concept of a virtuous
cycle
um where open source tools generate
demand there are great tools for data
scientists they're free but then you
need to transition often to like working
in a corporate setting where you have
privacy or you need to work with teams
and so then you need Enterprise tools to
enable you to use those open source
tools and so those are the products that
we build and sell and then we use that
to invest back in our pro products and
our Open Source Products and obviously
this is hard this is a big business like
there's 300 people JJ Lair is going to
talk next about Cordo and build this
business like this is non-trivial but I
think it hits a lot of these marks of
like aligning your mission with your
ways of generating Revenue thinking
about how you bring income
um thinking about governance structure
there's
um 43 people working full-time on open
source at posit and even more working on
other pieces of Open Source within the
company but then even just within that
there are hundreds of Open Source
projects and we actually don't
necessarily govern them all the same way
so it's kind of a really interesting
ecosystem around a lot of these
different pieces that we consider of
Maintenance and I think one of the
things that's particularly great about
it too
is that because we have so many open
source developers this idea of community
of practice so you in this room on our
own
there is a community that is working
together in open source and pause it
like we get to experience it like every
day like that I get to see my colleagues
at this conference is amazing you know
them like slack with them it makes such
a difference to have other people
working on open source at the same time
but there's a lot of other organizations
out there that help create new
structures
my carbon treaties are for data science
these Pi data meetings Pilots inside
pylonies are ladies snow focus and it's
important to not go it alone because
when you're feeling like maybe this
isn't like I'm not good at this it's
actually hugely not true it's just that
it's hard and so finding other people
that you can share with learn from is
really important in this space
so we in this room are building roads
and bridges maybe transitioning to
running Crews but we don't have to do it
by ourselves we can talk to each other
we can develop resources we can share
them with each other and so uh this was
a little earlier stage of this talk
um than I would have planned on but I'm
giving a workshop on managing an open
source project at closetcom 2023 in
Chicago in September and I'll have all
the materials online but the ideas like
some of the things that I talked about
templates decision making opportunities
to practice with like conflict or how do
you handle code of conduct like these
are skills that we can learn just like
anything else and so developing
resources to learn those things as well
as learning how to code
you can hear JJ's attack next on Cordo
it's the best it's like my favorite
thing I actually gave a talk on it being
one of my favorite yeah like at our
studio comp I said these are a few of my
favorite thing about court
representations and in that one I sang
poorly and I will not do that here
um and you can check out High openside
which is a great place around community
of practice in Python package
a great Community developing good
resources so I will stop here I think
there's a few minutes for questions
um I'm happy to talk about whatever you
want to talk about open the door on
conversations that we can continue later
as well so thank you so much for this
opportunity
[Applause]
thank you